we'll jump to this next story we got
some timcast.com Bud Light to release
camo print bottles in attempt to recover
from Dylan Mulvane Fiasco ah they're
like help yeah come on you guys are
really I think take a look at this
they're doing this on the eve of Pride
they're going with camo for pro wow Bud
Light sales wow at the end of uh at the
end of uh May 6th was down 27.7 and you
can see all of their uh Anheuser uh uh
Bush's Brands ABI Brands and Anheuser uh
Bush inbev have dropped and this is what
the street says new Bud Light data
suggests outrage against company is
waning what does that really mean what
the reason why sales aren't getting any
lower is because they've lost already
around 30 percent of their sales so
close to one-third let's just say a
quarter of their of their customers have
dropped them
as this spreads it will probably stay
around this number based a lot of people
don't care a lot of I went to a grocery
store they had Bud Light right in front
I didn't even I didn't even think twice
about it there was uh it was like have a
barbecue like have a go out and Grill
and have tacos and then it was a bunch
of stuff like taco shells and I was like
whatever and then the whole there was a
row with both sides was all Bud Light
right and coolers and I thought I
thought it was funny I was like oh look
at that all the Bud Light and I didn't
realize it until later I was like oh
wait they moved all the Bud Light to the
front of the store and it was on sale I
just I love how sorry I always kick this
thing I'm A Hazard I I love just the the
blatant hysterical overcompensation
they're like get no we're not gay we're
army guys yeah no we're army guys now
yeah we know for sure look at us I got
camel beer we're camo now hold on hold
on wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
last week camo is it Navy camo
the brand is blue so they might go for
the navy blue I love the thing everybody
was mentioning like the Navy made blue
camo it's like you fall in the water and
no one can see you oh my gosh what's
your point of that they're like hold on
we have to push away from this
reputation let's do something manly
military service I got it it cuts to
their commercial in the Navy
like what is the best military branch we
have a great idea no I think this is
sort of a crazy answer I hope that
anyone can see that this is such a gross
way to try to sell your product off the
military Stolen Valor a little bit it's
a little bit Bud Light really wanted to
sell their products this is what they
should do and I know it's gonna sound
sane but I think they should just start
infotaining infiltrating Pinterest with
like a thousand ways to cook using only
Bud Light like worlds of Honor programs
right to be like it's cheap you can get
Bud Light very it's not expensive right
now some places you can get it for free
dude and you can cook it in your slow
cooker you can do all these things but
you have to use Bud Light eventually
that's the only way to sell your product
you have to pretend that you're not
actually a drink you're just actually
some random ingredient I am getting more
and more Angry reading about this I am
seriously pissed off reading this
Anheuser-Busch will produce bottles of
the camouflage print and images of the
folds of Honor program which provides
educational scholarships for children
and spouses have fallen and disabled
American military service members and
First Responders according to the
executive no no no no no no no
earmuffs if your children are in the
room you have been warned you Bud
Light go yourselves this is
probably 10 times more offensive than
anything they could have done they spit
in your face they mock you behind the
scenes they talk in private about how
they know you're mad and they refuse to
apologize and then they say I know let's
shove disabled military veterans in
their faces as if that will absolve them
of their responsibilities this is the is
the most offensive way in my opinion to
respond to the backlash to well the
first thing they did was bring up 911.
serious wild they're like we're not gay
911 Army America don't you see that
Clydesdale we were good guys the horse
we ride horses we ride we ride horses
911 Army also this uh Foundation I feel
sad for them because they're going to
also get backlash like no don't care
legitimately doing trying to do good
work like why why would you accept a
partnership with Bud Light right now
like I don't care how much you think
they're worth this is a bad idea
yeah if they if if a company wants to
align themselves with Bud Light that the
only thing this European company is
doing it's not an American company is
repeatedly kicking Us in the stomach
over and over and over again
just don't buy their products I mean
you're trying to placate American
consumers and I think it dovetails
honestly kind of perfectly with the
whole Russia hoax it's like we're gonna
lie to you we're gonna offend you and
your values for this long period of time
but you still need to like buy into the
American system you still need to trust
the authorities you still need to trust
the FBI you still need to buy our
products we're not going to change
anything yeah we'll give you the Durham
report we'll vindicate you slightly yeah
we'll partner with like you know some
911 charity but it's like no we're done
with you like you said I I won't use the
word but it's
Corporate America they needed to they
needed to come out and be like hey look
we're really sorry about this we had a
you know marketing VP who wanted to it
won't work endorse and we we think the
campaign was not appropriate for our
audience we didn't mean to offend
anybody so we hope you'll stick with us
we will not be pursuing campaigns like
this in the future I'd have been like oh
that was that was really straightforward
and very nice of them instead they just
keep laughing behind the scenes and
they're getting what they're they're
doing these tricks to try and make it
seem like sales are returning and all
they keep doing is instead of assuming
responsibility they absolutely refuse to
say we were wrong
we were wrong sorry guys we that was we
were wrong and they're just digging
their they're digging deeper and deeper
and deeper I gotta be honest I I think
saying they're wrong still would not
undo the damage I think a lot of dudes
aren't just gonna see this is a gay
brand from now on it's going to gross
them out for that reason they're not
going to want to be seen as gay or
they're not going to want to support it
so they're not going to buy the beer
that's it if they came out we're like
hey uh sawi was an accident like our
wonderful elected leaders do and the
people the FBI it's still it still
wouldn't do anything I think these woke
Marketing Executives though their their
brains are so infested like they have
drunk the Kool-Aid on all of these
social issues that I also think that
they also don't even actually want to
make money for their companies right
that's not like in their DNA right doing
that as another cardinal sin that you
can't engage with and so I think these
people have always used these platforms
to push social agendas so they're not
going to apologize because they're like
no we're using this venue this Avenue
for the explicit purpose that we were
hired for and I'm sure they have EI
beyond belief in terms of their hiring
processes so you're self-selecting for
these loons they already disavowed Dylan
Mulvaney behind the scenes but they
refuse to do it
up above the fold they refuse to do it
in a statement they're going to their
investors they're going to the
Distributors and saying we don't have
anything to do with this we disavow but
then the customers who are angry they're
like ignore those people they don't
matter instead we'll make a camo print
and say disabled veterans over and over
again there you go that'll get our
customers they want it to be like now if
you aren't taking your beards because
you hate disabled veterans where it
could be you you're like I just haven't
forgiven you for the past I mean I wish
they would just go dark you know what I
mean I wish they would just stop for a
while let yourself Fade Into the evil
land I think people won't forget I think
you're right but I think trying to start
another campaign is only digging further
into the hole right like now it seems
like you are just acting in the most
smarmy way you're insulting military
veterans you're insulting the people who
want to support military veterans you're
supported you're insulting your audience
and you're not making yourself more
likable in the process like nothing is
going to repair this the best thing they
could do is to just stop talking for a
while something funny Sheamus no nothing
something you want to share
nothing sir just gave me a piece of
paper with an idea on it that I also had
earlier about it so you admit that you
steal his ideas nothing no it's it's a
cartoon that uh might be worthwhile it's
about Bud Light I'll mention after the
show we wouldn't want to spoil it but
they've totally tanked themselves it's
really embarrassing what they're doing
is it was super gross but they've
continued to be disgusting I don't see a
way out of this for them man I really
don't if they're unbelievably fortunate
people will forget but that's probably
not no it's just they keep they keep you
know the best thing could have done is
nothing if they did nothing if they made
no commercial no Clydes Gill Clydesdale
no 911 no folds of honor and just
literally said guys shut up and we just
drop all marketing and we're just gonna
sit back and then everyone would be like
well you know they did that thing that
one time I'm not gonna buy and then it
would have just tapered off instead
they're like can we every week punch our
customers figuratively in the face
what's also yeah it's just wild like as
if that's they're going for this
low-hanging fruit right that they know
people agreed which is really insulting
like 911 is something you're supposed to
have reverence for because a lot of
people died it was an attack on American
soil to be like oh you know what will
come out as like anti-911 or caring
about the fact that 9 11 happened and
that'll make up for the fact that we
pissed off all of our customers and
they'll start to relate to us again as
insanely insulting it's like insanely
insulting it's it's it's it's cultural
to not buy this product yeah there's
there's video there's someone posted a
photo with a CVS swear it's on sale they
brought all the beer to the front and
they're like uh on clearance I went to a
liquor store and I was like oh are they
going to put a Bud Light I didn't sound
like where's the Bud Light that's and
then right there right by the door it
said Bud Light sale sale yeah all of it
on sale and you walk in and they have a
big shelf trying to get rid of it the
product won't move yeah it's good I saw
somebody sent me asking on Twitter it's
like 4.95 for a 30 rack wow that's crazy
we had uh some of the staff here were
mentioning that they were at a local bar
and they asked the bartender bartender
said they can't move it at all so they
took it off tap and put Coors Light in
because nobody will buy it you can't
move a product what are you gonna do and
this is what people don't realize though
and this is part of why it's been so
effective everyone's arguing oh this is
such a such a good move by conservatives
on the part of the culture or or this is
such a huge victory in the culture where
on behalf of conservatives
I don't know how much of this is
actually culture war in the sense that
people who are invested in culture and
politics are paying attention to it and
strategizing so much as it's just normal
people being grossed out well I think
that's part of it it's a Grassroots uh
indication of the culture war that that
it's not just about people who are in
positions that are adjacent to the media
it is about what the public actually
will tolerate what they want I mean we
talk about all time voting with your
dollar this is the ultimate vote with
your dollar moment they don't want
companies like Bud Light essentially
making fun of them and assuming they'll
take whatever advertising is doled out
to them and they'll go along with it and
I think that's a really powerful moment
I mean in some ways it is I think
something a lot of conservatives will
look back on and say like we had an
influence like yes I'm sure anheuser-bus
is suffering they're about to face
massive layoffs there are probably uh
really serious Financial repercussions
and there are people at Bud Light who
don't deserve that right who didn't who
were never in a position to make these
decisions on the other hand I'm really
grateful that as a culture there was
something that we drew a line at thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time